hello
my name is jebum jung i am the lead
kernel developer
working for uframe research in the field
of graphs
and network during my presentation today
i will be discussing about the current
status of graphs and network
what's new and also what you are doing
for the future version of
warframe language as of today
we have about 170 graph series symbols
in ultra language we believe we cover
the most essential area
in graph theory
this chart shows how the number which
version graph shall
increase over time for example
we first added 97 symbols in version 8
which is the first version we introduced
graphs in system
not as a package after
that we keep feeling what's
left in the field also working on
improving
existing functionality and moving
vertically like
working with other area or blueprint
language or
doing some side project
let's start to check what's new in
visualization aspect of
graphene network the first is labeling
two label vertices we can use vertex
labels options
and ultron language automatically place
what is labels near vertices
for example here you can see vertex
labels
positions top left
of each vertices but the top right side
of labels
looks fine but other fat like here
you see the vertices got inside of graph
drawing that lower
visibility so we'll develop
new automatic behavior that works best
for each specified
specified embedding or layout
so for example here you
see the grip layout we
set the circular embedding
and if you check this same command in
latest mathematica
so like here now you see all the label
placed outside of graph drawing
not intersecting any edges or vertices
so this is not just for succulent
bedding
here i will show you the gallery of how
this new automatic behavior looks at
different embedding
so for example like balloon embedding
bipartite embedding
circular embedding and gravity so you
will see
all different kind of embedding with the
new behavioral labels
if you don't want to this new behavior
you can still recover the old behavior
or
you can specify specific placement using
like
placed so next
is constraint layout or coordinate
when you draw graphic i mean grabs you
can manually specify
vertex coordinate using vertex
coordinate options
like this example giving
all coordinates for each vertex zero
comma zero there comma one one comma one
and it
draw based on the given coordinate
this is how work before but in new
version like
2.1 you don't need to specify
all coordinate for each vertices like
you can only specify the
coordinate of vertices you want like
this example you see
i just specify coordinate for vertex 1 3
4 5. we sell two
and if you learn it you see all the
vertices
placed by your specification
but vertex two automatically competed
based on other vertex coordinates
and you don't need to giving poor
coordinate
when you're specifying it for example
here 3m4
i specify only y coordinate and let
x coordinate compute automatically by
saying automatic
for vertex 5 i just specify
same thing y coordinate or you can just
specify x coordinate
and if you evaluate it then you see
for for especially for vertex 3 you see
it is
on the one y coordinate but x coordinate
automatically computed
based on surrounding coordinate
and this constraint scheme is not just
for 2d
you can use for any dimension for
example like in 3d
this is automatic baby cell specifying
vertex coordinate
and here's i just specify 1 3 5
and you see everything works fine
and following this specification and
other vertices
computed automatically like i said this
is not just
for 2 and 3 i mean this is
you can extend to any dimensions but as
you know
i we can draw the graphs more than like
a 4.
so in this example i just specify four
dimensional coordinate for
these three and instead of drawing
because we cannot just using function
graph embedding
to extract the coordinate so here
you see this we got the four dimensional
coordinate and then
all the requirement is satisfied
let's check the new behavior of
highlight graph
highlight grab is the function to help
you highlight element
of graph you want for example here
you see the case when you highlight the
single groups of element
so vertex 1 and eight connecting one and
two
highlighted with steeple twilight style
you see here
and next is the case
when we want to highlight multiple
groups of vertices and edges
so for example here two groups
are automatically styled with two
different color
it's like kind of red and yellow
and this is nice feature to distinguish
different groups
but it doesn't really follow the default
highlight style you see
for single case or nor highlight style
specified by user
so we go further in the new version
so that it color differently like here
and also maintain specified style
and this is the new behavior
we implemented in the new version
now you can see not just color
also it follow the default highlight
style
the next slide will show you the gallery
of
highlight graph in case of multi groups
so all the style like dashed
dotted d is nicely maintained
with different color that depends on the
group you specified
in this slide we'll check the change in
the layered graph plot
layered grappler is the function that
generates a layered plot of given graphs
this is the typical example of how
layered graph plot works
so the second argument saying we want to
place two vertex 2 on top
so if you evaluate this input you see
the plot that place 2 on top
but what if you want to place several
vertices on top not just like two
the new argument we added is you can
list
root vertices so that multiple vertices
placed on top
or specified position like left
right or bottom so for example here
i set 2 and 7 on top
and labeled automatically and if you
i evaluate it now you see instead of
just one
like previous example you see 2 and 7
on top of flat
and feature i introduced so far are
already in the
latest version of mathematica so you can
use it
and now i'm gonna show you something we
are working on
so this is not in the the
version available but it you will see in
the new
picture of mathematica
first layered red plus 3d you already
see
layout grab flat that generate layers
plug into this paste like this one
and layer the graph flash 3d
as you can guess by name is the
function that generates layered plot in
3d space
here are the some basic examples so this
is the case
the applying carry trig graph of 9 to
layer 2 laplace 3d
so as you can see here
vertices on each layer is nicely
positioned
and you see gray layers
inserted to each level so that you can
easily verify vertices on each layers
so in order to do this
like other plotting function
you can style layers with different
color or any directive
you want so here's the example
that i just set up face grid style to
faster
so it's follow faster color and instead
of just gray
layer you see the nice different colors
so you can easily
distinguish layers by color
other options may be available is like
change
type of layers and
colors for this by layer etc so here's
some example like
this one you see instead of the the
grade it just
you know have bounding kind of
box and here's you see the the vertices
are colored differently and this is mix
of those two
effects
another function we are working on is
graph value flat
this is the function generate a plot of
graph
in which the vertices and the edges are
styled
according to the values for example here
i try to plot a graph based on degree
centrality
and at default as you can see the output
the size of vertices changes based on
the degree centrality
so you can specify all vertices like
saying buttons list
or you can specify like each vertices
or edges with certain values
and you can also specify which style you
want to change
based on given value not just size you
can change its
colors or thickness of edges
so here's some examples of
graph flat like this one changing
size and color based on the given value
and this one
changing the excitingness and this one
is changing edge colors
so we hope this function helps you to
easily style graphs
based on certain parameters like any
value you
provide
other project we are working on is
visualization of logic graphs
like a millionaire point plotting large
graphs
are not like an easy problem so we are
trying
several different ways to attack this
problem
for example like first sampling and
reductions
this is the method to reduce size of
graft flat
so for example we can just randomly
sample
the point or you can reduce the graph
with certain property so that it reduced
to lesionable size but still
having the important graphical pictures
we don't want to lose
second we already have four strict
layout scheme
which is pretty fast and
but we can even go further by adding
like a multi-threading
in full selected or
other ways it's like we are using like a
multi-level scheme
inside of post-directed layout and
we plan to kind of expose that
multi-level
to use for visualization
and there's many other like a
visualization technique out there for
logic lab
so we also just working on those
before we check the last new in
visualization
and now let's check what is new in
computation aspect in urban language
so find spanning tree is the function
that
return the spanning tree of given graph
and
the new version we extend that input to
not just graph to like a point
or the string or even judas point
so for example here we just put
some random two-dimensional point and if
you learn the fine spinning tree
on this point you see it's kind of
it using the the pointed coordinate of
the graph
and then finding like smallest spanning
tree
out of this point it's kind of similar
to find the
store you if you plug in the point in
fine shoot
store you get like a shortest
tour that minimizing the the true
distance so
given point this is same exactly same
you got the spanning tree that minimize
the euclidean distance distance between
point
and here you see the given point and
then
the spanning tree so it's not just
one two dimensional you can also
applying the three dimensional point and
then you got the spanning tree on the
three dimensional space
this was working on 4d and andy space
like i said it's not just point and pull
string
and this finding spinning tree if you
apply string it'll compute
spanning tree based on edit distance
so also you can apply but plug in the
geo
the the point
okay this is also like future the
direction we are heading
like a visualization we also dealing
with the large graph
in computation effect for example
sometimes your graphic
graph is too large you cannot even
loading into mathematica in memory
so that's why we come out of core graphs
so instead of storing all the graph in
the memory restoring the graph in the
hard drive or
external hard drive and then we're just
loading
portion of graph when it needed there's
the console the
concept of out of graph and also
that using the gpu is when you're doing
computation
so currently they're like a gpu comes
with some
library even for graph computations
so we can using that accessing
and using it also we can even extend
those library
so we can get the benefit of gpu
computation in
mathematica
so last thing i'm gonna talk about this
bridge
what it means like we have many great
graph and network functions in open
language
and those functionality is not just
useful for area of graph it it can also
have
other area so
first step will be for doing that
is converting something to graph
so here's for example like uh for image
we have function called morphological
graph that convert
image to graph for example like
this image you see nicely
structured graph out of this image
and then you can compute many more
things
using this graph and get some idea of
your original image
and other function is like in geometry
we have function called mesh connected
connectivity graph
new in version 12.1 12
which convert given mesh to graph
so this input second input form you can
specify zero
or zero comma two
means the point one is line so that's
the line in the
mesh graph so it giving the relationship
between
each cells so using this function you
can
check some of the topological aspect of
your mesh
like a finding hole and
check his meshes connected or what i
mean is closed
or not
and at last list like an expression
graph
that giving the expression structure
any mesmerised friction
and giving this nice tree graph
so this will be the last slide of today
and
thanks for i mean watching this
presentation and i really hope
you got some you know
you got some useful
idea of what's going on lately in urban
language
in the field of graphic network
thanks for attending and if you have
further
want to get further information you can
check the the
graphene network documentation
and the tutorial something like this in
the web or even in
america so thanks
uh yeah boom this is uh bruce coletti
again
i do have a question are there any plans
to some
future version to uh uh
build uh the uh group
of a graph uh you know the the the uh
the group of automorphisms associated
with a
given graph so
silicon the kind like like the
isomorphism we have
there's the imaginable pigeon right
well i'm not so into the the isomorphism
part
i want to be able to deal with the with
the group
uh that emerged from a given directed
graph
and i'm wondering if maybe you and jose
mark garcia the developer for the group
theory package
have ever had discussions along that
line other grocery packages yeah we have
in the system and yeah we
not right now but as i know we
are planning to extend those
functionality also so yeah
yeah okay so it's a list of things to do
okay good thank you i'm not on youtube
but yeah you can also send like a
you know to the as you know like
technical support for
asking so they can be on the list
more quickly so yeah but we definitely
have some yeah
discussions about that yeah
yes it will let me uh ask this question
this might be a little off the
reservation
um are there any plans to
uh extend the functionality
of the function and i forget what its
name is
uh that comes up with a a solution for
the
uh traveling salesperson problem
you mean the fight financial test tour
uh uh that that sounds like it would be
the the right function i i'm just
drawing
find postman yeah we have find first
mentor function yes
uh well well all right so i'm not so
much interested in the
solving the postman problem as i am
involving the
traveling salesperson problem so you
know i do know
that when the uh number of cities is
suitably small that you can solve it
in a straightforward manner but when
number of cities gets too large
you have to to trigger uh heuristic
methods
exactly yeah yeah and uh i'm just
wondering
if there are any improvements uh to
finding heuristic solutions uh
that you that you are now working on or
will be working on
i mean right now even the fine post
mentor will find the short store
logic graph is automatically triggering
your listing method
holistic method
right now so okay
these are these heuristic methods that
are triggered in the postman
sales person problem are they
proprietary to
wolfram or are they uh can they be found
in the literature
and and if so then you know what i'm
going to ask
okay is there a reference that you could
give to all of us
uh yeah that can be considered because
right now
i don't think we have kind of option to
find tuning for holistic method it's
kind of automatically kick-up
and unless you set up like a pokemon
scores to
quality then it will try to find the
near problem
it proves like automatical speed then it
will kick up the holy state method
okay okay
okay thank you yeah but if you want to
order it
soon then that's another yeah
probably suggestions but
right now we don't have it hi everybody
so
like i said we have meetups so you can
join that
if you have more questions yeah sounds
good thank you bye